[Music]
hi all
uh thank you i want to thank
biodiscovery and bio nano for
allowing us to present
our
work on ngs homologous recombination
deficiency
my name is chris lum i'm the medical
director of molecular diagnostics at
diagnostic laboratory services in
honolulu hawaii and with me today is
um
zan halford zen can you
introduce yourself
hi all
my name is zan and
i am a technologist and i've been
closely working with
dr lum for
eight years now and
we have been
quite a
a
paired of colleagues for um next-gen
sequencing and expanding on that in
in the island and the state of hawaii so
it's good to be here
thank you
and so
i'd like to present we're excited to
present our work on ngs homologous
recombination deficiency particularly in
the sense of expanding
ngs capability to look at larger
structural
genomic or chromosomal alterations
our goals today would be to
describe homologous recombination
deficiency
as a
way it is infected by dna damage and its
role in cancer therapy and we
particularly focusing on high-grade
serous ovarian cancers
we'd also like to summarize the method
of software evaluation because this is a
bioinformatic challenge to be able to
take ngs data and look at these things
beyond that
and lastly we'll describe some of the
performance of this ngs solution to look
at this genomic alterations and describe
some of the performance and limitations
of using ngs data to look at these
changes
so where does the story begin you know
the story begins with how our cells
handle dna damage
and
there are a number of ways and this is a
graphic that shows some of those
first there are single strand dna damage
repair mechanisms the first is base
excision repair looking at altered or
damaged nucleotides the next is nucleic
nucleotide excision repair where
chemical alterations of nucleotides can
be edited and the last in this category
is mismatched repair or where bases are
mis
associated
but the more significant damage to our
chromosome happens with double-stranded
breaks and in that category there are
primarily two mechanisms in which those
are handled the first is one that is
prone with error called non-homologous
end joining where it is randomly
associated with the other with a
a pair of dna close by and this can
often lead to error as well as
translocation
a far more elegant approach to
dna
double stranded damage is homologous
recombination repair in which the sister
chromatid is used as a template for that
repair
when cells have an alteration in that
ability to
have homologous recombination that's
called homogeneous recombination
deficiency or hrd
and
there are a number of mechanisms which
can cause homologous recombination
deficiency
the one that is primarily highlighted is
bracha one and two mutations and that is
known for decades now
but there are other mechanisms that can
cause a homologous recombination
deficiency that prevents a cell from
repairing these types of defects
some of them are somatic
some of them are not bracha 1 and 2 but
are part of other genes that are
involved in this type of repair
bard 1 pal b2 for example rad 51c
there are also epigenetic causes
that
also
affect homologous recombination
deficiency and when we are in a state of
hrd it it
affects the way in which our cells have
the ability to repair
double-stranded dna breaks and it
promotes a state of genomic instability
this genomic instability can now be
leveraged for cancer therapy
so how do we look at hrd status well we
could look at and in the past we looked
at simple germline mutations maybe if we
just did ngs to look at snip and indel
changes in germline mutations for these
genes that are involved in hrd that
would be one way of looking at it the
next is somatic alterations that maybe
genes that have been altered on a
tumor-based level can
have a ability to affect hrd that's
another way to look at it
but the more comprehensive way of
looking at hrd looks more at the outcome
of all of the different things that
cause homologous recombination
deficiency and looking at the effects of
what they are meaning that we look at
genomic instability and by doing that we
look at genomic scars and in looking at
genomic scars we look at three
parameters loss of heterozygosity
telomeric allelic imbalances and large
scale state transitions
and that's shown in the purple boxes
and so why do we do this well we're
trying to promote an idea of synthetic
leaf lethality or
where
a cell is able to repair
double-stranded dna breaks by the genes
that it has to repair and it uses an
enzyme called parp
and when those two mechanisms are
working okay
the cell is able to
carry on with repair and carry on with
living
if one of those genes were to be altered
braca or bracha-associated genes
harp is still able to step in and repair
double-stranded dna breaks
and if a cell were to
have
a defective or inhibited parp
those bracha genes will also be able to
continue repairing dna breaks but when a
cell is
has a mutation in braca or a mutation in
braca associated genes and also and we
also are able to block
that
uh parp
enzyme that is the ability now to cause
cell death and that's synthetically
lethality it was leveraging alterations
in bracha and brach-associated genes
such that we can cause cell death by
making the cell
the cancer cells unstable for life
continued growth
and so this is a perfect case for
ovarian serous cancers
epithelial ovarian tumors um have
demonstrated significant sensitivity to
parp or polyadp ribose polymerase
and some of the parp inhibitors that
have been used in this field are
alaparib who have who has original
indications for bracha-associated
cancers
and that that's been associ that has now
been assigned to
all lines of therapy for ovarian cancer
both front line switch maintenance and
also recurrence there are other players
that are part of parp inhibitors
naraparib and recapperib
and so if you look at the ovarian cancer
landscape with regards to hrd
it is not just involving bracha 1 and
two but it also involves other genes
rad 51c also amplifications like a
cyclin e1
mz and also losses like p10 so just
looking at single nucleotide changes
indels and copy number changes isn't
able to solve all of the ability to
detect hrd
in particular if you look at this
this uh area right here where i thought
which i can't point to for bracka one
and two promoter methylation epigenetics
is also a method in which um hrd states
can be
achieved that can't be detected by
standard ngs platforms
and what we're trying to do is enhance
standard of care for ovarian cancers so
the standard of therapy for variance
serious cancers are surgical debulking
and followed by platinum and taxaine
based chemotherapy and that puts
patients about 75 of patients into
remission but about only 30 of them will
be cured and when those
other patients the other 70
that have recurrence those tend to be
chemo resistant and so this is a perfect
situation to now look for molecularly
targeted
therapeutics to handle those patients
that are not sensitive to standard
chemotherapy
and this is where the assessment of hrd
comes in so we can look for germline
alterations and we can look for somatic
alterations but we really need to be
able to look for
the
hrd states to find the indications to
now use homologous recombination
deficiency to justify the use of parp
inhibitors
carbon inhibitors are also being looked
at now not just for ovarian serous
cancers but for other cancers like
ovarian prostate pancreatic and breast
cancer so for
institutions that are running ngs
platforms having an ability to use hrd
or ngs data to assess hrd and genomic
instability really enhances your ability
to provide the full spectrum of
biomarker targets for your oncologists
and surgical oncologists
and i'm going to pass it over control
exam to show how we can use that ngs
data to assess hrd
thank you dr lum
so our next
set of slides is going to discuss how we
are leveraging
summarize summarizing software and
leveraging what we we can use
as far as
moving away from a traditional array
uh methodology to using next generation
sequencing massive parallel sequencing
here
and summarizing the pie chart of how dna
can be damaged
the assays that you see here
kind of tear through
getting to
opening up to larger evaluations of the
genome and its instability
you can see in the blue box the
dna damage response and repair gene
alterations are are certainly sought
after as well as the homologous
recombination repair
genes here
and you can see where
we have assays
leveraging
those they're also now leveraging
whereas in down in the red we see the
genomic scar
types present
these
assays out here in the commercial space
have
um
are our next generation sequencing
assays and they both have
two different approaches
you can see
one is
selecting for a genome-wide loss of
heterozygosity
evaluation
no basically reported as a percentage
and
another
has a larger box of surveying
loss of heterozygosity loh
telomeric allelic imbalance tai and uh
large state transitions or scale
transitions lsts we call that the
genomic instability score um
and
we are going to reference
that and percent loh
as we move through
howard in-house our in-house validation
compares to both
this
next slide
is really
the process of
a commercial labs effort as well as our
own
to try and do what we can with
leveraging
all of the literature out there
assessing each of these states
collectively as we aggregate
what
they do evaluate
and
this is a data evaluation of
being able to visualize that they are
happening
in the tumor
it
is that
more data is is better data so
the aggregation of all of the states
seem to have a better predictive
response than just evaluating one
i want to now
kind of break open just to define what
each of these states are
on
the left is a nice diagram of different
ways that you can see the loss of
heterozygosity which
is
where a represented parental allele has
been deleted
with
respect to
the literature what we're looking for is
where that
is occurring over a span of 15 megabases
but also shorter than the whole
chromosome
the telomeric allelic imbalance is
similar there is a
misrep there's a loss of representation
of a parental allele
or an imbalance
depending on the type of copy number
change whether it's gained or
lost and
with respect to the literature again we
as you see down below cited in the
coming slides we need
to evaluate these
at a size greater than 10 megabases
and finally
with the large scale state transitions
lsts
what these are are events of instability
that are greater than 10 megabases
what we distill from this
is we are actually counting the two
breakpoints
that homologous repair deficiency
shows us where the the the cell cannot
repair its double-stranded breaks
so when we refer to lsts we're
we're often just trying to discuss the
number of
times we see
state changes and thus the breaking of a
dna to
then become
abnormally represented whether in
the allele frequency or the copy number
you can see that we do want to exclude
centromeric
areas as telomeres also um as for those
centromeres are in the center and
the telomeres are at the very end of the
basically the chromosomal arms
so we have to
be
respectful to it there's ambiguity as to
why certain things during mitosis and
meiosis may actually
co-occur and so
we rule those out in our
scoring
calculation
and then lastly we do want to make sure
that
when lsts are close together such as
there are micro
there's a micro section between two
state changes there needs to be at least
three megabases of
of genetic material that's in a similar
state
in order to count really close break
points together
as you see
when we want to
find the sum of the the gis the genomic
instability and in our sense we call the
hrd scoring
we need to
add up all of these together
and basically also to assess them as
as they are now aggregating together
with
respect to biodiscovery's nx clinical
software that x is so
small uh we have in the title there and
we have
a
the this display here to show you that
through some permutations we've
you know
now maintain that
you can have overlap of both telomeric
allelic imbalance as well as
uh as well as a loss of heterozygosity
present
also to the right you can have
shared
lst changes
and as we said we need to distill to the
breakpoints
so in in sharing this
it's
it changes a way that we evaluate what
what is present
or i shouldn't say it changes i should
i'm sorry should clarify that
in evaluating it
we can both have two things co-occurring
and and so evaluate that both things are
co-occurring
here is
a table of how
the nx clinical software that we're
using
displaying today
classifies what it what it sees
and as we are now getting towards how do
you add up
what's
what is present as a scar and assign it
about an integer of weight
um
we look at this table to
to show that every x here will
will gain a presence integer an integer
of one
and the ls t's that are present
will
be counted as
their present and excluded if they need
to be
and counted once if they're shared like
in the former slide you saw can happen
so as we look in towards on the right
side where the
the green section is is sorting out
the integers whereas the
um on the left you see sort of the many
iterations or permutations that
the scar classifications can exist
this is um
refined now and
is
a part of what they offer as an
automatic calculation for us
as far as being
in development with them it has
really really been a a great leg up on
understanding
the
the ways that all of these um
scars can coexist
so
here is a tumor sample presented to you
one of one of ours
in
in the software
it would be
fortuitous to do this obviously most do
and they show you
an ideogram of the genome
so
if we look
for a minute at this you can see that
there's
red and blue
which
discuss a gain in blue and a red loss
state change
across the p and q arms of each of these
chromosomes
you can now also see down in the lower
left there are the three
genomic scar classifications present in
the legend is purple yellow and black
so
if you look uh a chromosome 2 you can
see that we're having
the shared
event of a
tai loh present here simply because of
the ideogram showing you overlap
so it happens and
quite often it is
an unstable genome looks looks like this
so
i'm going to take us through quickly
the
calculations of each of these events
for
the
loss of heterozygosity
ideogram here
you can see
that
the
the data is classifying that a
greater than 15 megabase
copy number loss event is is happening
you can
you see the data visualized here that
there are
a state change
uh in
involving two different break points in
the interstitial area
so
we have a tai or i'm sorry an h or d loh
and two break points happening here
in other examples we have in this
a q arm
loss
and
this
is is classified as an hrd loss
but we have to exclude the two
breakpoints being that they land in the
centromere and the telomeric regions
so for these two examples
our our scoring here is shown
we have an into the integer of the
presence
is the integer of one or zero so we have
on the left we have an hrd loh present
as well as on the right
however the left differs because of the
two break points
and the right does not have any that we
can include
so
you can add one and two is three and
that
is what that simple event is
adding to
the overall assessment of each genome
we go scar by scar
and in the end we have
total score represented
so we've got two more we have the
telomeric allelic imbalance next
to cover this is
any
gain loss
or
allelic
loss of heterozygosity that extends to
the sub telomere but does not cross
into this the centromere
and it must at least be greater than 10
megabases
so i am showing here
a
telomeric allelic imbalance it is also
the overlap of a loss of heterozygosity
so it's one of those ones that fits tai
loh in the middle of the venn diagram
that we showed earlier
you see the telomere involved
on the rightmost side of the zoom in of
the q arm and then you also see
where the state change of the lst had
occurred
so
with the
summation of this event
we need to look at do we do we see the
loss of heterozygosity the loh
classification present we do
and
do we see the telomeric allelic
imbalance
scar classification present we also do
nx clinical has made that
tai loh its own it is the pink
classification
um
visual
there
right under the chromosome ideogram
i add that that's here and that's
helpful because it does
train your eyes to understand you can
have the the software help you color
code that
it's it's frankly a great way to learn
and
sorry for the tangent now we also
finally do see that
in order for that to have happened you
needed the state change of course
that is the lst break that's also
present at the point where the copy
number
track shows that there is a loss of
content
so
in in total this
sums up three points
towards the the total genomic
instability score
finally you've you have seen as we've
gone through
that
without any of the former to
the the the state change has to happen
for any of the former two
events we were just speaking of to
happen
so he's kind of a mutual evaluation
at that time but i'm just going to ask
us real quickly to focus
on
looking at the break points themselves
and how that they can
co-occur
so
on on the left you see
oh these are two examples of basically
showing you
the
types of lsts you may see
you may see co
events occurring to classify like on the
right
and
this is something that nx clinical has
worked very hard to
to evaluate and allow
automatic scoring towards
and
it's it's a really bright new future to
be able to
evaluate these much more quickly than
than formerly in a in a manual sense so
i must commend them for
working very hard to do that
i
see that
on the left we're going to focus on this
one first
and
what you see here is the two breakpoints
and
the classification of the hrdloh
we've seen this slide before
as well as this on the right we now
we see that there is
a gain
and there's also a secondary
zygotic event
happening
so
this one is a
situation of evaluating
what's here we see a
set of break points
and we also see the gain end at the
centromere
so by excluding the centromeric
involvement
and calculating the two breakpoints that
we see present
this gives us
two in total
i am
uh now gonna pass it back to dr lum to
speak on
our studies and
comparing the
percent loh
and
the genomic instability score
and finally rounding out with
how chemotherapy response scores
may or may not be
concordant with
um
evaluating parp on its own for
potentially changing the way that
we approach when we should do
hrd testing
so how did we do
using zan's
and our hrd scoring technique we wanted
to see how we compared to other
laboratories that were assessing hrd and
the first was percent loh
and what we did was we took a small
series of cases that were run by outside
laboratories looking at percent loh and
it was a range of different tumor types
both ovarian pancreas breast
prostate
and these are other cancers that have
the potential for parp inhibitor
indication and what you can see is that
it had a
not encouraging sensitivity
and there were some discrepancies here
and for example the ones that we have in
yellow um the ovarian cirrus and the two
rows from the top would had a bump above
the positive loh percentage call 16
being the cutoff for
loh high
and um below 16 loh low and so this was
called
um high at 16.2 and our hrd scores were
three and the other one was
the prostate adenocarcinoma which
had a
high loh at 19
and our hrd call was low 42
being
our
cut off
and but it just shows that there is a
discrepancy in loh and hrd and that was
echoed in a poster at last year's asco
identifying the fact that loh and hrd
are don't have good concordance and that
makes sense because
hrd scoring has so much more involved in
determining an hrd deficiency beyond
simple loss of heterozygosity and i
think that this
table highlights that
if you look at our test performance of
hrd calling versus percent loh you can
see here that it has
a non-impressive sensitivity at 60
and so this was encouraging and that
some you know we had
some concordance but it wasn't where
we felt it was
adequate in terms of
assessing
a patient for the ability for parp
inhibitor indication
still understanding that
in the literature there is a
these these states of percent loh and
hrd may not be um
equal and that hrd might be a better
more comprehensive assessment of true
hrd status
so the next
comparison we did was basically looking
at
apples to apples
let's look at what true comprehensive
looks at hrd deficiency and genomic
scarring look like from a orthogonal
view so this is an outside laboratory
that uses genomic instability scoring
and we took a number a small series of
high-grade serous ovarian cancers
and looked at the call for
their their genomics scarring and we did
our assessment of hrd's of our hrd
status and found an encouraging result
in that we were able to identify or
mimic and correlate
in this small series
fairly well the um the status of hrd
high and hrd low
this is our test performance here
basically showing that it was a good
concordance study but in a very small
series but encouraging in the fact that
um
our solution to use ngs data using the
bio discovery index clinical software
bioinformatic pipeline is able to assess
the status of hrd in a way that can
reflect
other laboratories that are doing this
study
we also took a
physiologic look at hrd and we compared
the chemotherapy response scores for
ovarian high-grade serous cancers and
this is a score that is used to
assess the
cancer's
sensitivity to
taxane therapy and so
after surgical resection and
neoadjuvant
um sorry
sorry
with neoadjuvant therapy followed by
surgical excision the tumor is assessed
for its response to
chemotherapy almost an in vivo
assessment of its ability to be
sensitive to that particular
chemotherapy chemotherapy and when there
is minimal response it's given a crs
score of one when there's a significant
response it's given a crs score of three
in the literature it's been
noted that crs three
serous ovarian cancers usually have some
sort of hrd deficiency and so in that
physiologic state we try to see if we
can compare
crs3 scores and see if those scores
could mimic an hr a high hrd status
based on our scoring and what we found
was discrepant
in that
there were a number of high-grade serous
ovarian cancers that were crs3 that we
had at we had an hrd low score for
and we were puzzled by that
but let's put that aside for a moment i
also want to point out that there are
other situations here where there was a
crs score of
one
but yet we still had a hrd score that
was high interestingly it this case is
very interesting to me because it
highlights the fact that there are other
things that cause a homologous
recombination deficiency state and so
this uh didn't have a bracha one and two
germline mutation it didn't have other
genes that were associated with hrd
deficiency but what it did have was a
null ph p53 phenotype which is another
indication where there's a homozygous
loss of p53 that is also a a
a state that can cause genomic
instability
and so in that um
in that mutation
this is the reason why it probably had a
high hrd
going back to the um the crs3 scores
where we had an hrd score that was low
this was very important and instructed
for us to see because this
showed that
tumor percentage was a significant
component to hrd scoring and that
when we had a lot of tumor to assess we
had very good hrd
concordance when tumor percentage
dropped
that hrd concordance also dropped
and this was significant in a real world
sense because if
um
in the standard of care where new
adjuvant chemotherapy is given before
surgical excision
oftentimes what happens is is that a
patient is diagnosed found a peritoneal
fluid where there is small cells that i
are identified as
having
an ovarian phenotype and that is the
diagnosis of ovarian cancer
when that diagnosis is made the patient
is given new adjuvant chemotherapy
and then surgical excision is is done
and then in that surgical specimen a lot
of the tumor is gone for crs three
scores
and in those situations all we have from
an ngs laboratory standpoint to work
with is a small cytologic preparation
with a few cells and then a tumor that
is pretty much
completely
destroyed by chemotherapy so there's in
those situations there's no tissue
available for an hrd assessment if that
patient recurred to see if that patient
is available for parp inhibitor therapy
and in the next slide that
sensitivity
to
tumor tumor percentage is highlighted
here
when we ran the same tumor but then
diluted that tumor percentage down from
eighty percent down to twenty percent
and then zan why don't you talk us
through these um these four panes here
sure this is a
data-heavy look at the four panes
of
i'm thinking it's a chromosome 12
example so what we see is in the upper
left with 80 percent
we find
our our index clinical classifications
highlighted
in gold and in pink
and as we took
the normal margin tissue from that
that patient's
tumors and normal sample or resection
sample i should say and and diluted it
out
we found that we lost the ability to
to detect what state changes were were
occurring
after
the first
dilution scheme of 60 percent
so
it it does stack up with the the ability
to calculate
the log the lr ratio that tells us
whether things
pass a threshold of being
a state change or not
and
and there's there's there's more to
to extrapolate i think from
understanding that and knowing
the
the sense of
the accurate
expectation of where the sensitivity
lies yeah i think that's
something to highlight is that that um
that drop happened quite significantly
and very early at
70 to 60 percent
so um you can see how much of an impact
that tumor percentage is for that hrd
assessment
and so
um this is the reason why an incident an
in-house institutional-based assay is so
important because
now we can work with our providers to
say that i know that the diagnosis is
going to be made on a cytologic
preparation but we may want to have a
tissue
source available
such that if this patient does
respond well to taxane therapy crs3
scoring we have tissue available to
assess for hrd
on follow-up if there's a recurrence to
to work with our clinicians to be able
to provide us the specimens available to
to help them out with therapeutic
options later on for this patient
and then lastly
zan you want to take us through this
slide
sure this is
just to finally touch on
what's
down the
it's available and was was down the pike
while we were doing our research
their next clinicals
most most latest
release is
integrated to like automatically
classify and and take
the genomic scar
patterns to help us
score and simplify our workflow
it
re it covers when
genomic scars are close together
so it's able to omit the small gaps from
being counted to the the rule that
they need to be a certain three
megabases apart
and
it does a a comprehensive way of
evaluating aneuploidy and and other
um mechanisms that will also
be ruled out of calling homologous
repair
deficiency
criteria that we didn't really touch on
and
and so
ultimately
the the automation of this is
is available
and makes this
a really refined
workflow to
be able to take your ngs data while it's
in the bioinformatic annotation pipeline
and
cooperatively allow
the hrd calculations to be assessed on
the the tumor types of choice
and then being able to use index
clinical both for ngs data
and micro array data is also helpful and
so for you know nextsiq 550 users that
are able to use both ngs data and also
the infiniium chip 850k chip
for
assessment of hrd
this is going to be very helpful you
know in it so to overcome things like
tumor percentage we'll be looking at
were what is the drop-off
for
a tumor percentage based on microarray
and we expect it to be somewhere around
20 so if this in this workflow would be
if we were not able to assess hrd by ngs
to be able to flip into
um
microarray assessment of hrd and then
still using the same bioinformatic
pipeline
is is going to be very helpful
you know to be able to report that data
we also look forward to maybe using and
seeing if we can do this by optical
genome mapping
which i'm sure that because bionano and
biodiscovery
both you know you know have that type of
collaboration it's going to be very
interesting to see how that data looks
are there any questions
thank you
you